in the depreciation video we saw that if
a company had to buy some equipment for
its factory let's say at the beginning
of 2007
just based on the cash that went out of
the door there might have been this
temptation to say okay in 2007 we had in
it i don't know what's called an
equipment expense
let's say eq expense
and they could have just wrote let's say
that equipment cost
fifty thousand dollars so they would
have just put a fifty thousand dollar
expense right in 2007. i write it a
negative number just because i like to
remember it's an expense although i
don't know if that's that's actually not
normally people just write it as a
positive expense but i always like to
put a negative for expense to know that
it's going to subtract from your revenue
so they would do that they would put
that cash expense there in 2007 and then
in future years maybe 2008
2009 2010 they would have no expense
until maybe they had to replace that
machine or buy a new one and we saw that
that i guess is one way to account for
things but it really doesn't reflect the
reality of the business the fact that
this machine
right here that cost fifty thousand
dollars is used for in this example in
the depreciation video we it was usable
for two years let's say in this example
it's usable for four years so what they
do is instead of just expensing the cost
of the machine
when the machine is bought on the
balance sheet at the beginning of 2007
they say we now have an asset
they now have an asset called a
machine i'll just call it m for machine
that's fifty thousand dollars
fifty thousand dollar asset at this
point right here right when we bought
the machine remember balance sheets are
snapshots in time and then instead of
having an equipment expense
instead of having that expense they'll
have any let's call it an
equipment depreciation expense
equipment depreciation
expense and the difference here is just
instead of saying that we
the the entire expense was that machine
in just the first period they're saying
no we're using some of the machine in
that period and let's say we do straight
line depreciation which means we
essentially depreciate the asset evenly
over the over its lifespan so in this
case we're assuming it's a four-year
lifespan so let me draw that out it's a
four-year lifespan so the
the asset should linearly go to zero
over these four years
so essentially in the first year our
expense would be what it's twelve
thousand if you divide fifty thousand
divided by four it's twelve thousand
five hundred dollars so it'd be
minus twelve thousand five hundred
dollars and each year depreciation
expense
minus 12
minus 12 500
and we would account for it on the
balance sheet because remember income
statements are just telling you how do
you get from one balance sheet to
another so expenses reduce the
the value of your asset so example in
this one at the beginning of the period
before the 2007 income statement
the asset was worth fifty thousand
dollars we depreciated 12 500 from it so
at this point in time the balance sheet
as of the end of 2007 or the beginning
of 2008 we're going to say that our
machine is now 12 500 less so 47
and then at the end of 2008 beginning of
2009 our balance sheet on under the
assets the machine if they gave us that
level of granularity would be 12 500
less than that so that's what 35 000
so the machine would be
35 oh sorry this is 37 000.
37 500 so then the machine is 25 000.
and then another 12 500 on the books
it'll say the machine is worth 12 500
and then at the end of 2010 it'll say
the machine is worth nothing and if we
did our depreciation schedule right or
if the lifespan of this machine really
is four years then it's time to go buy
another machine and start doing this all
over again and this is all a review of
the depreciation video
amortization is the exact same thing but
it deals with intangible assets what's
intangible well it's something you can't
see touch feel smell
eat
obviously a machine you can't do all of
those things to it but you can at least
touch it and and possibly smell and
taste it so an
intangible asset is something you can't
do any of that stuff too but it's the
exact same idea for example
let's say we are some type of well i
mean whatever we could still be a widget
company and let me write down the years
and 2010
and let's say that
if we just did it from a cash point of
view let's say we had to buy a patent in
order to make our widgets so we could we
could have said oh we had to buy a you
know patent expense
we had to buy a patent from some
brilliant investors inventor someplace
patent expense
we could just say oh you know what the
patent it costs four thousand dollars so
we could just put that there even though
the useful life of the patent might be
four years
and so it doesn't reflect the fact that
we still are using that patent in these
years and we just take the hit here and
so this income will look unusually low
while these will
these will look unusually high it's not
reflective of the fact that you're using
this patent that has four years left on
it so instead of doing that what you do
is
at the beginning of the period so you
don't do this at the beginning of the
period you say we have acquired a patent
an asset that is worth four thousand
dollars
and then every year over the life of the
patent we'd amortize a fourth of it
since it has a four year life so it
would be patent amortization
patent
amortization and there's all sorts of
intangible assets that you might
amortize and amortize amortizes really
just means spreading out the cost of
this asset just like depreciation was
spreading out the cost of a physical
asset so patent amortization would be a
thousand in this year
a thousand in this year a thousand in
this year and a thousand in this year
and then
at the our snapshot or our balance sheet
at the end of 2007 we'll have on its
assets a patent that's now worth 3 000.
and then at the end of 2008 it'll have a
patent that's now worth 2 000 end of
2009 i think you get the point you'll
have a patent worth
1 000. and the end of 2010 probably
because the patent has now expired and
anyone can go out and and produce
whatever was that that that invention
that was patented without having the
patent we then say that the patent is
worthless and this could actually you
know a very relevant thing is if you are
a drug company and you were buying the
patent to some pharmaceutical that had
four years left so that you can have
exclusive rights to develop that drug
and
at this point all of a sudden now anyone
can develop the drug so that patent is
worthless so the balance sheet is really
trying to capture what your asset is
worth at that point in time at this
point in time your patent is arguably
only worth a thousand dollars because
you paid four thousand for four years
now you only have a year left but that's
all amortization is nothing nothing
fancy let me amortization i didn't write
it out nice and neatly in case you want
to know how to spell it it really in my
mind it's very similar depreciation
depreciation is tangible amortization is
intangible it could be patents it could
be licenses it could be
fees associated with the financing let's
say you have some debt that you took
from a company and the debt is going to
last for uh 10 years and you have to pay
a one-time lump sum fee to the bank well
that one one-time lump sum fee should
probably be spread over the life of the
debt so you would amortize that expense
over its life anyway see in the next
video